[Musique]
bonsoir à tous
alors aujourd'hui je vais vous parler du
pouvoir de l'intention créatrice dans
nos chemins de vie alors il est
important pour moi de présenter déjà de
voir dans mon parcours à quel moment
j'ai compris qu'on avait un pouvoir
qu'on pouvait tout changer et comment
avant j'étais sans et ce qui fait toute
la différence alors comme vous pouvez
voir écrire derrière moi je m'appelle
Babacar Sané mon père et sénégalais il
vient du Sénégal de l'ethnie Joola et
vient de la brousse vraiment c'est un
endroit perdu au Sénégal on appelait ça
le grenier du Sénégal donc c'est
vraiment là-bas où c'est vert et ma mère
vient de Python Sainte-Rose donc c'est
un peu le côté aussi perdu de la Réunion
donc voilà et comme j'aime le dire je
suis Sénégalais mal barre sénégalais de
mon père bar de la Réunion et ce qui m'a
fait rire c'est qu'un jour j'ai répondu
à quelqu'un qui me dit mais quels sont
tes origines je suis Sénégalais malbar
ça existe pas je suis là devant toi ça
existe
donc très tôt j'ai été confronté à cette
représentation qu'on avait de moi
physiquement ou même intellectuellement
et pourtant je suis né en France donc je
me sentais aussi français
donc je vais raconter un peu mon
parcours je suis né en France j'ai fait
les allers-retours entre la France et la
Réunion
et j'ai fait des voyages bien sûr pour
découvrir la culture de mon père et en
allant au Sénégal on me disait alors les
réunis
bien sûr je le partageais parce que
c'est la culture de ma mère qui
connaissait pas quand j'allais en France
on me disait tu es étranger toi tu es
pas français
et ce qui était le plus étrange c'est
que quand je revenais à la Réunion on me
disait mais toi tu es africain j'ai dit
mais alors du coup qui je suis qui je
suis POUR VOUS qui je suis pour moi-même
parce que c'est ça qui est le plus
important
du coup je continue à grandir et à
évoluer
et j'aime pas l'école je pense que
l'école ne m'aimait pas aussi puisqu'ils
ont arrêté le contrat ils m'ont dit bon
on va séparer de toi et tu vas te
débrouiller tout seul dans la vie
c'était un peu trop rigide pour moi on
choisit assez matière et puis surtout
c'était des choses froides je partageais
pas on a imposé beaucoup de choses
grâce à ma mère qui m'a franchement
poussé à continuer elle m'a dit mais
passe ton bac candidat libre vas-y ça
t'engages à rien
j'ai eu mon bac en candidat libre j'ai
raté de peu la mention ce qui est
incroyable parce que j'ai pas beaucoup
travaillé
je continue et je me dis mais là
qu'est-ce que j'ai envie de faire et
qu'est-ce que j'avais envie de faire
c'était de partager ce que je voyais en
Afrique
c'était magnifique je les voyais sapés
quand ils allaient au mariage je les
voyais ça fait quand ils allaient à
l'église je voyais saper même à la
maison je me dis par contre on n'a pas
ça ici pourquoi on est on est dans une
société conforme on oublie s'habiller
avec des tailles qui fait du 34 on fait
du 34 et demi on fait du 35 on fait du
37 et je voulais sortir de ça donc je
voulais transmettre ce que je voyais sur
les marchés la richesse des tissus la
richesse de la culture africaine et donc
j'ai ouvert ma première entreprise
et quand j'ai ouvert un prêt à
l'entreprise j'étais en perte relooké
par les réactions des gens et première
action c'était celle de ma mère et
pourquoi tu fais ça pourquoi tu te
casses la tête aller dans un pays que tu
ne parles pas forcément la langue et
puis les autres tours ah c'est difficile
ça fait pas ça il ressemble pas où ça
écoute à moins je comprenais pas et j'ai
même quelqu'un qui m'a dit mais moi ce
que je te souhaite c'est c'était un
vieux du village qui donnait les
bénédictions avant que je reparte je te
souhaite que tu trouves un métier que
quelqu'un t'embauche que mais c'est pas
ce que je fais c'est pas ce que j'ai
envie de faire donc c'était assez
particulier
mais quand j'ai ouvert mon entreprise je
pense que je l'ai fait avec la peur j'ai
fait avec la peur de ce que les gens
allaient penser de MOI je l'ai fait avec
la peur de comment il pouvait le faire
et malheureusement on est un peu jeune
j'aimais un peu faire la fête je pense
aussi et je l'ai fermé je l'ai fermé
donc j'ai repris ma je repris mon
train-train j'ai recherché à des petits
boulots
et puis ma mère encore qui vient et qui
me dit bon écoute tu as passé une fois
ton bac en candidat libre vas-y tu peux
continuer ton chemin donc j'ai fait une
validation des acquis je suis rentré en
Licence Sciences de l'éducation ça a été
un peu une révélation pour moi parce que
les sciences humaines sont des sciences
vivantes et ça me parlait beaucoup plus
j'apprenais beaucoup plus sur moi donc
je continue j'obtiens ma licence
et j'arrive en master
en master je découvre une
matière qui s'appelle l'anthropologie
et dans cette matière l'anthropologie
mon professeur me fait découvrir un
concept qui s'appelle le génogramme et
je ne gramme qui est beaucoup plus riche
que l'arbre généalogique qui met les
profils physiologiques qui met les
caractéristiques qui met beaucoup plus
de renseignements et à ce moment-là je
savais que je tiens le prénom de mon
grand-père j'apprends comme mon
grand-père en fouillant avec ma famille
était le premier dans sa région à faire
importer un cas à faire importer un
camion qui faisait l'aller-retour en
Dakar et la Casamance c'est 600 km et
qu'il a été donc un instigateur de ça et
je certifié j'ai appris ça
mais j'ai continué quand même à faire
j'ai dit bon continu et dans ce jeu-là
il y a quelque chose qui m'a été
transmis par ce professeur qui s'appelle
le fantôme de la crypte le fantôme de la
crypte c'est-à-dire les transmissions
conscientes et inconscientes qui a dans
la famille
consciente et inconsciente donc
qu'est-ce que j'étais conscient de ses
peurs qui étaient transmis quand ma mère
me disait mais c'est pas ton chemin
pourquoi tu vas faire ça
je me suis dit bon j'écoute ma maman je
vais au bout de mon master
j'obtiens mon Master et mon Master en
fait le mémoire il était sur le
traitement des énoncés créole en classe
et à ce moment-là je me suis retrouvé
à redécouvrir l'histoire de la réunion
d'une autre façon à rechercher vraiment
comment le créole s'est fermé quelle
place il a aujourd'hui dans nos vies
dans notre quotidien et surtout qu'elle
place il est à l'école
je me rends compte que c'est vraiment
complexe l'esclavage est très proche les
engagés sont très proches ayant encore
beaucoup de choses qu'on transmet
inconsciemment beaucoup de choses qui
sont en nous qui nous empêchent parfois
d'avancer
j'obtiens mon master
je continue donc à faire la fête
et
c'est un petit île
c'est un petit tige je me dis bon
continuons d'avancer c'est pas grave
c'est du passé et il m'arrive un
événement assez particulier j'aime pas
dire tragique je perds ma copine en 2014
d'un accident de voiture très violent
donc c'est une mort soudaine qui nous
surprend
et ce que j'aime à dire aujourd'hui
c'est que dans la mort j'ai découvert la
vie pourquoi la vie parce que à ce
moment là je repris le pouvoir créateur
que j'avais pourquoi parce que je me
suis posé la question bien sûr après
l'extinction du deuil mais qu'est-ce que
je fais de mon temps est-ce que je suis
en train d'utiliser mon temps pleinement
est-ce que je ne le gaspille pas quand
je me lève le matin qu'est-ce que je
fais vraiment pour être heureux est-ce
que je fais semblant est-ce que je suis
pleinement moi-même
et je me suis dit je reprends
mon vieux rêve chiffonné que j'avais
fait il y a 10 ans quand personne
n'entendait parler
du wax je le reprends mais avant de le
reprendre je l'ai préparais différemment
puisque maintenant
j'y vais et je regarde plus derrière
donc voyage je fais la déco je
redécouvre l'océan Indien et puis je me
lance et à ce moment là c'est
extraordinaire la ça me dépasse les gens
qui viennent me parler les gens qui
viennent échanger avec moi qui viennent
découvrir un vêtement ça me dépasse
je me rends compte à quel point
les difficultés que une personne lambda
va voir l'entrepreneur il va avoir des
opportunités je vais voir à quel point
le vêtement devient un objet social je
porte donc je suis
ce que je porte reflète ce que j'ai
envie d'être ce que j'ai envie de
transmettre et ce qui est le plus
incroyable
c'est que ça m'oblige à me redécouvrir
moi-même ça m'oblige à aller chercher le
sens des tissus ça m'oblige à aller
chercher réellement plus profond ce que
je fais
et c'est là où il est important pour moi
de bien nécessiter le titre
le pouvoir de l'intention créatrice dans
nos chemins de vie quand j'ai dit ça
Jean-Max Jean-Max il m'a demandé mon
titre il m'a dit tu peux être plus clair
j'ai dit mais le titre il est là c'est
clair qu'est-ce que tu veux de plus
et en fait je me suis rendu compte que
c'était pas clair le pouvoir c'est
quelque chose qui est extraordinaire
c'est quelque chose qu'on donne aux
super-héros c'est quelque chose c'est le
président qui a du pouvoir c'est le
ministre mais vous avez ce pouvoir qui
utilise ce pouvoir pleinement quotidien
qui en est sûr
donc le pouvoir de l'intention
l'intention de visualiser l'intention de
se projeter
créatrice donc de créer quelque chose
qu'on ne connaît pas
quelque chose qu'on va découvrir quelque
chose qui va nous obliger à nous
dépasser quelque chose qui va nous
pousser à ouvrir une porte de l'inconnu
pour peut-être d'abord nous rencontrer
et ce projet était
alors ce pouvoir
il est il est à vous mais si vous le
laissez aux autres
que ce soit dans les intentions qui vous
donnez les peurs conscientes et
inconscientes qui sont ancrées dans
notre manière de faire les peurs qui
sont ancrées dans nos êtres dans nos
familles si ma famille qui était très
instruite ils ont tous réussi par
l'école parce que mes grands-parents ne
savaient pas lire
et pourtant ils ne connaissait pas ce
chemin d'entrepreneuriat donc ils
avaient peur pour moi ont bienveillance
il me disait de prendre un autre chemin
mais ils avaient peur pour moi et donc
il faut se débarrasser de ça
c'est très important se débarrasser de
ça comme un terrain brut
qu'on veut plan qu'on veut planter où on
veut planter des fruits ou des arbres
fruitiers peu importe
un terrain où il faut déblayer il faudra
déblayer les ronces il faudra les payer
les cailloux il faudra déblayer
peut-être le nettoyer
c'était très important pour moi
de me projeter
ne me projeter sainement librement
alors ce pouvoir il s'agit pas comme ça
évidemment il y a des conditions et
Edgar Morin un auteur que j'ai rencontré
dans dans mon parcours scolaire lisez
une chose qui me sent très très
importante
nous nageons dans un océan d'incertitude
avec des péninsules de certitudes donc
j'ai compris que pour accepter ce
pouvoir créateur il fallait passer par
l'humilité de dire que je ne sais pas
parce que faire quelque chose qu'on
connaît déjà
où est l'innovation où est la création
où est le plus où est votre sensibilité
ou est-ce que vous apportez est-ce que
vous répétez les mêmes choses est-ce que
vous faites du mimétisme ou est-ce que
vous donnez de vous-même mais vous
donnez pleinement
le temps
le temps est une notion très importante
parce que j'ai redéfini ma journée j'ai
redéfini mes 24 heures en 24 heures
qu'est-ce que je pouvais faire puisque
quand les clients venaient vers moi
j'ai dû réapprendre à coudre non j'ai dû
apprendre à coudre j'ai dû apprendre à
coudre j'ai dû gérer mes pages Facebook
Instagram faire des stories gérer les
photos les scénarios et tout ça je me
suis rendu compte que mais finalement ma
sensibilité ce que je ressentais me
donner envie de faire je connaissais
peut-être pas les caractéristiques
principales mais juste avec mon
intention de faire juste avec la
visualisation la projection et comment
j'organisais mon temps
ça donnait quelque chose de magnifique
et aujourd'hui même ça me dépasse
puisque je ne pensais jamais apprendre à
coup de départ
ni je ne pensais jamais prendre des
photos lui conseiller pour les pauses ça
me parlait pas c'était pas ce que je
voulais transmettre
et ce temps là il est très important il
est très important parce que c'est un
processus c'est un processus le pouvoir
créatif c'est un processus qui va
s'installer ce n'est pas une réponse que
vous allez trouver du jour au lendemain
c'est pas une solution adéquate
c'est quelque chose qui va se mettre en
place en continu pour vous permettre
d'être vous pleinement
et de pas chercher à répondre
automatiquement
mais trouver des réponses alternatives
et différentes
parce que ça vous demande de soit sortir
de sa zone de confort ou moi j'aime
préfère dire agrandir sa zone de confort
ça vous demande de tellement de vous
débarrasser de vous
vous quand je dis vous c'est les peurs
et dans ce temps qui vous est donné
aujourd'hui moi je vous pose une
question est-ce que vous utilisez votre
pouvoir créateur
posez-vous la question
et
à partir de ce moment-là
projetez-vous
projetez-vous sans peur sans crainte
sans attente
mais avec une direction
une direction de réussir de se
satisfaire pleinement d'être content de
se lever le matin de pouvoir dire
simplement
j'y vais et le soir j'ai fait mon
maximum
pour ne pas avoir de regret pour ne pas
avoir de remords parce que ce temps est
précieux et que chaque sensibilité qu'il
y a aujourd'hui devant nous elle est
importante
toute ce Val
et elle est propre à vous il n'y a pas
deux personnes comme vous
on est un peu comme des diamants
ou
comme le diamant qu'on trouve dans la
boue qu'on va commencer à nettoyer on va
le déposer chez le joli on va déposer
chez celui qui va le déposer sur le
bijou et qui va le transformer mais
c'est bijoux des fois il reste enfermé
dans un coin ils sont pas utilisés
et là on va être un diamant continue
c'est dire qu'on va pas déposer ces
idées dans un coin mais on va les
projeter en continu pour que chaque fois
qu'on fait un pas dit pas il soit guidé
vers notre réussite merci à vous
[Applaudissements]